swashbuckling on the seven seas can lead
to a whole lot of danger the pirates of
the caribbean cast and crew grew to know
this well over the years seeing brutal
injuries and very close calls on set
let's check out 15 of the injuries this
cast and crew suffered while on set
number one
this doesn't sound fun filming the
pirates of the caribbean films over the
years has been hard on death's body
filming on stranger tides depp explained
that he had a bit of a physical ailment
i must have done something to my back
during a stunt and ended up with this
bad sciatic situation and how was he
feeling exactly well the actor described
it as horrible grinding electricity
unfortunately with so much money on the
line and a tight filming schedule the
actor couldn't stop and take time off to
recover he had no choice but to film
through the pain while he looked great
on screen depp was limping around the
set when the cameras weren't rolling
number two a first aid kit was always
close by caia scotlario made her mark as
a newcomer in the pirates franchise and
threw herself into the deep end
unfortunately she did wind up suffering
a bit of damage filming dead men telno
tales saw the actress fall on set
leaving her with an arm injury so bad
she was stuck in a sling for a while it
costs to be a pirate with this crew
number three this one lasted for a while
it was only the second film when johnny
depp was injured so badly on set that he
literally suffered nerve damage in his
left foot filming the big wheel scene
that featured captain jack swashbuckling
on top of the wheel while it was rolling
along was dangerous to film no doubt but
what's ironic is that it was one of the
safety measures in place that did the
most damage depp was strapped onto the
wheel tight to make sure he wouldn't
fall off but because they filmed for
such a long time the injury was
unexpectedly rough deck was pretty
honest about how serious it got
explaining i had no feeling you could
stick a pin in it and i wouldn't have
felt it note to self don't pull any
straps too tight ever again
number four she's expected to sword
fight in a corset kira knightley's first
foray into the pirates world saw her
wearing a very very tight corset while
filming including for throughout her
more stunt heavy and physically
demanding scenes to say she was
uncomfortable is an understatement
because when you got a corset on my
waist was about 20 inches and you
absolutely can't breathe fortunately
following the first film nightly was
dressed in more practical clothing for
the action she was tackling
number five you've heard of a flying
dutchman but flying wood it's not really
something you want to know about
unfortunately johnny depp came face to
face with flying wood and he can attest
that it's a brutal experience not all of
the ropes between the ships were cut
once the interceptor started to move and
the boats came apart a bit the ropes
between the ships came ripping down
catching everyone in the production off
guard to make matters worse the lions
were knocking large beams of wood on the
ship out of place leaving one flying
directly into johnny depp the actor was
hit in the right knee so badly he was
knocked out of the frame completely you
know he was limping for a while after
that one
number six it looked and felt pretty
rough by the time filming had wrapped
for stellen skarsgard on the pirate set
he was looking more and more like his
character without the prosthetics on the
bootstrap bill turner actor was fully
made up to look like his character which
meant there were a painful 4 hours spent
in the makeup chair before even starting
work when the filming did begin it was a
race against time because the makeup and
prosthetics started to really aggravate
the actor's skin skarsgard's face was
getting covered in rashes forcing the
production to limit themselves to
filming with the actor for only three
days at a time just to allow his skin
the chance to breathe and recover hoping
to prevent any permanent damage if that
weren't bad enough a full hour and a
half was spent at the end of the day
removing it all
number seven it's a risky business
johnny depp's stunt double tony
angelotti saw what was essentially the
end of his career while filming dead
man's chest the yo-yo stunt that sees
one captain jack sparrow spinning out of
control went tragically wrong and
angelotti really did spin out of control
doing a rehearsal only to be left
hanging by his leg after an 80 foot drop
what went wrong the stuntman explained
when i was up looking down i gave the
call of three two one go they pulled my
quick release that would allow me to
unravel however the operator of the
descender did not have the brake on and
i went into a free fall the performer
was in seriously rough shape suffering a
bad acl injury that needed
reconstructive surgery and severe
internal bleeding resulting in a total
loss of six units of blood and going
through it was just as painful as it
sounds angelotti described it saying i
spun so uncontrollably fast that the
centrifugal force actually ripped my
pelvis apart i felt the ripping inside
my pelvic area the burning ripping
sensation after a long time spent in a
wheelchair learning how to walk again
the stuntman returned to sets doing some
lighter stunt work and stunt
coordinating work but his career would
never be the same as it was before that
accident
number eight yes seriously this beard
was literally on fire throwing back to
curse of the black pearl we've got
jacoby played by vince lozano who wound
up being a risk to himself and others on
set because of his literal flaming beard
instead of resorting to cg the special
effects and makeup team went all out
making a full fake beard with wires
hidden inside that would allow for
incense to be lit releasing smoke while
filming any time the smoke would let up
the beard would get relit once again
however sometimes it got a bit out of
control and the beard fully caught fire
you kind of always smell burning hair
around this guy both the actor and
people around him were left with some
nasty burns from the long beard hair
whipping around
number 9. swords equal danger pretty
much all of the time before his near
fatal injury tony angelotti suffered a
sword to the face while battling orlando
bloom it was time to film their
blacksmith forge fight but things
started to go haywire when as angelotti
put it orlando i think got lost at one
point and went in another direction and
i ducked back and the tip of its blade
caught right near my eyebrow it was a
very close call and while the stunt
director was ready to move on johnny
depp was quick to insist angelotti get
the right treatment and be checked over
by a medic fortunately angelotti only
suffered a small scar in the end of that
one
number 10 putting things in your eyes
often leads to some struggle keira
knightley was wearing colored contact
lenses in the first pirates of the
caribbean movie these lenses were
outfitted so she had dark spots in the
center with a lighter color around them
the problem with these lenses though was
that they made the actress extremely
dizzy and unable to do her job nightly
knew it would be a total headache to
keep up with that throughout filming so
she ditched them tossing the lenses in
the trash after just one night of
filming number 11. again stuff in the
eyes not fun mackenzie crook faced a
struggle with his contacts as well
instead of lenses to change his eye
color though the actor wore double
contacts to give the appearance of a
wooden eye when asked to describe the
feeling the first word he used was
uncomfortable it may not have been ideal
conditions but it definitely lent itself
well to his pirate acting
number 12. what kind of injury wasn't
there during production this one didn't
happen on set specifically but the
accident did impact the making of dead
men tell no tales johnny depp suffered a
brutal hand injury offset that led him
to being flown to the states to get a
surgery done just one month into the
process and this injury delayed filming
as they were just getting into the swing
of things and unfortunately for that
production it was just the first of a
few injuries that caused delay these
pirates all lived to tell the tale but
it was not easy and many of them didn't
leave unharmed somehow which scene would
you have been most nervous to tackle
[Music]